Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家播客福利、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及我们备受喜爱的聊天社区会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我总是拼不对。所以你只能用一个假名，比如你咖啡馆的名字，朱莉娅。但你用得越多，就越觉得自己在接受证人保护。等一下。朱莉娅到底喜欢什么样的浓缩咖啡？现在改拿铁还来得及吗？但如果你有一台 KitchenAid 的浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些烦恼了，因为你完全可以在家里自己做。
Shop now at KitchenAid.ca The love that dare not speak its name in this century is such a great affection of an elder for a younger man as there was between David and Jonathan, such as Plato made the very basis of his philosophy, and such as you find in the sonnets of Michelangelo and Shakespeare. It is that deep spiritual affection that is as pure as it is perfect. It dictates and pervades great works of art like those of Shakespeare and Michelangelo, and those two letters of mine, such as they are. It is in this century misunderstood, so much misunderstood,
立即访问 KitchenAid.ca 购买在本世纪，那种不敢说出名字的爱，是年长者对年轻人的一种伟大的挚爱，正如大卫和约拿单之间的感情那样，正如柏拉图将其作为其哲学基础的那样，正如你在米开朗基罗和莎士比亚的十四行诗中所能发现的那样。那是深沉的精神之爱，既纯洁又完美。它主宰并弥漫于莎士比亚和米开朗基罗的伟大作品之中，以及我那两封信中——尽管它们也就是那样。在本世纪，这种爱被误解了，被极大地误解了，
that it may be described as the love that dare not speak its name, and on account of it I am placed where I am now. It is beautiful, it is fine, it is the noblest form of affection. There is nothing unnatural about it. It is intellectual, and it repeatedly exists between an elder and a younger man when the elder man has intellect and the younger man has all the joy, hope, and glamour of life before him. That it should be so, the world does not understand. The world mocks at it and sometimes puts one in the pillory for it. So Dominic, that was the celebrated speech given by Oscar Wilde at his second trial, completely off the cuff, where he is defending himself against a charge of gross indecency that has been brought to him in the wake of the collapse of the libel
以至于它可以被描述为不敢说出名字的爱，正因为如此，我才落得今天这个地步。它是美丽的，是美好的，是最高尚的挚爱形式。它没有任何不自然的地方。它是理性的，并且经常存在于年长者和年轻人之间，当年长者拥有智识，而年轻人拥有生命中所有的喜悦、希望和魅力时。世人无法理解这种爱本该如此。世人嘲笑它，有时甚至为此将人钉在耻辱柱上。多米尼克，这就是奥斯卡·王尔德在第二次审判中发表的著名演讲，完全是即兴发挥，当时他正在为自己受到的严重猥亵指控进行辩护，这项指控是在他针对昆斯伯里侯爵（Lord Alfred Douglas, Bosie 的父亲）的诽谤诉讼破裂后随之而来的。在这篇演讲中，他非常明确地谈到了他自己和波西，并否认其中有任何猥亵成分。这是一场精彩绝伦的演讲，汤姆。当时有人说，这是自圣保罗在希律·阿基帕面前辩护以来，被告发表过的最精彩的演讲。这是一场非常、非常非凡、优雅、清晰且感人的辩护。
trial that he has brought against the Marquess of Queensbury, who is the father of Wilde's lover, Lord Alfred Douglas, Bosie. And in that speech, he is pretty clearly talking about himself and Bosie and denying that there is anything indecent about it at all. It's an amazing speech, Tom. It was said at the time that it was the finest speech of an accused man since that of St. Paul before Herod Agrippa. And it is a very, very extraordinarily elegant, articulate, indeed moving defence.
当然，正如王尔德的传记作家马修·斯特吉斯（Matthew Sturgis，其传记《奥斯卡》绝对精彩）所指出的那样，问题在于，实际上王尔德受审并不是因为他和波西的关系。他受审是因为他所谓的轻罪——当时的人们会这么称呼——对象是一连串 17 和 18 岁的办公室男孩、文员、侍者、仆人，而这种描述并不真的适用于这些人。嗯，虽然我认为，王尔德本人或许也会对此提出异议。他辩称，实际上在他与年轻人的关系中——用那个时代的话来说，这些人在智识和社会地位上都远逊于他——存在着一种交流，他是在分享自己的文化，分享他的品味并教育他们。所以这实际上就是他所提出的论点。
Of course, as Wilde's biographer, Matthew Sturgis, absolutely wonderful biography, Oscar, as he points out, the problem is that actually Wilde is not on trial for his relationship with Bosie. He's on trial for his misdemeanors, as they would have called it at the time, with a succession of 17 and 18 year old office boys, clerks, waiters, servants, to whom this description does not really apply. Well, although I think, again, Wilde would perhaps dispute that. And he argues that actually in his relationship with young men who are, in the language of the age, very much his intellectual and social inferiors, there is a kind of communion that he is kind of sharing his culture, he's sharing his tastes and educating them. So this is actually kind of the argument that he is kind of sharing his culture. He's sharing his tastes and educating them. So this is actually kind of the argument that he is making.
但在此之前，让我们先提醒听众们，我们上次讲到这场悲剧的什么地方了。奥斯卡·王尔德针对昆斯伯里侯爵的诽谤诉讼已经破裂。逮捕令已经发出。两名便衣警察来到卡多根酒店将他带走。他被驱车送往苏格兰场。他根据 1885 年《刑事法修正案》第 11 条被指控与其他人男性做出严重猥亵行为。他被带到鲍街警察局，登记备案，并在单人牢房里过夜。而在圣詹姆斯剧院，他的伟大喜剧《不可儿戏》曾是伦敦炙手可热的剧目，他的名字正悄悄地从广告和节目单中被抹去。是的。所以我们正处于 1895 年。汤姆，我们应该说，你和我仍然在华盛顿特区的这个公园里，就像我们上次那样。
But before we get to that, let's just remind our listeners of where we left this tragedy. So Oscar Wilde's libel case has collapsed against the marks of Queensbury. A writ for his arrest has been issued. Two plainclothes policemen have come to the Cadogan Hotel and taken him away. And he is driven to Scotland Yard. He is charged under section 11 of the 1885 Criminal Law Amendment Act with committing acts of gross indecency with other male persons. And he is taken to Bow Street Police Station, booked, taken down to a cell for the night. And at St. James Theatre, where the importance of being earnest,
所以如果你听到儿童哭泣的声音，那是因为他们认出了汤姆·霍兰德——电视上的汤姆·霍兰德——他们吓坏了，生怕他对他们进行模仿。完全没有那种风险，但是，是的……就在他被带到鲍街警察局的第二天，确切地说是第二天，听证程序在鲍街地方法院的高级审判庭开始了。现在……酒店和爱德华·卡森爵士——我们上次讨论过的那位未来政治家，他曾是昆斯伯里侯爵的出庭大律师——这次他不是皇家大律师了。
his great comedy has been the toast of London, his name is quietly being removed from the advertisements and the playbills. Yes. So we're in the year 1895. And Tom, we should say, you and I are still in this park in Washington, D.C., where we were last time.
他的副手查尔斯·吉尔。查尔斯·吉尔提出了针对王尔德的指控，他非常条理清晰地提出了这些指控。他说，我们有一连串的证人。我们有所有这些约会的细节。证人们描述了他们与王尔德的相遇。他说，我们有一连串的证人。我们有所有这些约会的细节。证人们描述了他们与王尔德的相遇。接下来是一连串的证人。
So if you hear the sounds of children crying, they've spotted tom holland tv's tom holland and they're terrified he's going to do one of his impersonations at them no risk of that but uh yes so the day after he has been taken to bow street police station the very next day the committal proceedings begin at the upper courtroom at bow street police court now hotel and uh sir edward Carson, who we discussed last time, the future politician who was the Marcus of Queensbys barrister, he is not the Crown barrister this time.
我的意思是，针对他的案子，汤姆，甚至在这个阶段，很明显他们掌握了一个非常、非常令人信服的案子。他们无情而有条不紊地汇集了证人，而且他们不仅有那些男孩或年轻人，还有酒店的工作人员、女服务员，他们有女服务员，他们有仆人。我的意思是，最著名的故事是萨伏伊酒店的女服务员，她说她感到震惊，她讲述了这个故事：她走进王尔德的房间，发现床单和他的睡衣上涂满了凡士林、精液，还有她所说的污物。我认为这些细节——我的意思是，这些都是最终登上媒体的细节，意味着
It's his junior, Charles Gill. Charles Gill brings out the case against Wilde, and he brings it out very methodically. He says, we have a succession of witnesses. We have details of all these assignations. The witnesses describe their encounters with Wilde. He says, we have a succession of witnesses. We have details of all these assignations. The witnesses describe their encounters with Wilde. Then there's a succession.
夜复一夜，晚报上全都是丑闻和指控。我们应该强调的是，实际上审判和指控的记录并没有在报纸上被完全报道，因为这被认为过于丑闻，不适合绅士们阅读。对。不仅如此，汤姆，我们还应该强调，此时的公众情绪非常、非常反王尔德。因此，报纸在呼吁对他的起诉。当诽谤案被撤销时，人群欢呼雀跃，支持昆斯伯里侯爵。例如，《国家观察家报》称，英国深深感谢昆斯伯里侯爵
I mean, the case against him, Tom, even at this stage, it's obvious they've got a very, very compelling case against him. They have ruthlessly, methodically compiled the witnesses, but they also have not just the boys or the young men, but they have the people who work to the hotels to the chambermaids and they have chambermaids they have servants i mean the most famous story is the chambermaid at the savoy who says she was shocked she she says it's at this point she tells the story she went into world's room and she found the bed sheets and his night shirt smeared with vaseline uh semen and what she describes as soil and i think those kinds of details i mean those are the kinds of details that find their way into the press and mean that
摧毁了颓废派的大祭司。老贝利法院必须进行另一场审判或死因研讯，后者为首选。对于颓废、对于艺术意义的 hideous 概念，必须彻底终结。所以在这一点上，
for night after night the evening papers are full of scandal of allegations and we should emphasize that actually the the records of the trial and of the accusations are not fully reported in the paper because it is seen as being too scandalous for, you know, gentlemen to read. Right. But not only that, though, Tom, we should also emphasize the public mood at this point is very, very anti-Wild. So the newspapers are calling for his prosecution. There are crowds that cheered the Marcus of Queensbury while its libel case was dropped. The National Observer, for example, says Britain owes a deep debt of gratitude to the Marcus of Queensby
很明显，这不仅仅是一个关于奥斯卡·王尔德的案件。正如我们上次所说，这现在是一个关于政治的案件，关于一个正处于回光返照之中的自由主义政府。这是一个关于对艺术颓废、对精英主义和唯美主义产生强烈反弹的案件。但我认为，部分原因也是出于一种不安全感，即王尔德到底被指控了什么。所以他被指控犯有严重猥亵罪。有一种观点——这是一种历经数百年、数百年、数百年的古老观点——即法律上所谓的鸡奸，是一种道德犯罪。
for destroying the high priest of the decadence. There must be another trial at the Old Bailey or a coroner's inquest, the latter for choice. And of the decadence of the hideous conceptions of the meaning of art, there must be an absolute end. So at this point,
这是人们选择去做的事情，就像他们可能选择去谋杀、偷窃或做类似的事情一样。但这正在受到一种从德国传过来的、关于性取向的新颖理解的挑战，心理学家们创造了一个混成词，结合了希腊语和拉丁语——同性恋。这种观点认为，实际上，如果你犯了鸡奸罪，你很可能会这样做。这不是因为你是罪人。而是因为你患有一种被称为同性恋的医疗状况。具体该如何构建、处理和理解这一点，你知道的，这是这些审判发生时的一个现实挑战。
it's very clear that this is not just a case about Oscar Wilde. It's a case that has now, as we talked last time, it's about politics, about a liberal government that's kind of in its death throes. It is a case about, there's a backlash against artistic decadence, against a sense of elitism, aestheticism. But I think in part, it's also about a sense of insecurity about what exactly Wilde is being accused of. So he is being accused of gross indecency. There's a sense that, which is absolutely a kind of venerable one going back centuries and centuries and centuries, that what in law is called sodomy, it's a moral offence.
我认为，因此也存在一种道德混乱和不确定的感觉，这为这一切提供了部分背景。所以王尔德已经搬到了霍洛威监狱。人们普遍认为——我们在今天的节目中会对此进行大量讨论——人们普遍认为王尔德被挑出来进行特殊对待，因为当权者想拿他杀鸡儆猴，正如人们所说的那样，对他特别严厉。事实并非如此。所以即使在这一点上，他在霍洛威监狱也有一间特殊的牢房。他被允许从餐馆叫外卖。他有书读，可以看信件。他有一连串的访客。他唯一伟大的访客是波西，阿尔弗雷德·道格拉斯勋爵，我们曾形容他是一个可怕的……
It's something that people choose to do in the way that they might choose to do murder or theft or something like that. But this is being challenged by a novel new understanding of sexuality that is coming in from Germany, where psychologists have invented this portmanteau term, fusion of Greek and Latin, homosexuality. This idea that actually, if you commit the act of sodomy, you are likely to be doing it. It's not because you're a sinner. It's because you have a medical condition that is called homosexuality. And how exactly that is to be framed and processed and understood, you know, this is a live challenge at the time that these trials are happening.
累赘。一个累赘，说得委婉一点。他基本上是世界上最糟糕的人。王尔德形容他像一件纤细的东西，金发如天使般，总是站在我身旁，在阴暗中像一朵白花般移动。所以。所以公平地说，关于波西，存在着截然不同的看法。我们能对波西说的是，波西对王尔德如此忠诚，是个如此正派的人，以至于他在审判开始前就离开伦敦去了法国。无论如何，审判于 1895 年 4 月 26 日星期五开始。
And I think, so there's a kind of sense of moral confusion and uncertainty as well, which provides kind of part of the background to this. So Wilde has moved to Holloway Prison. It's often thought, and we'll talk about this a lot in today's episode, it's often thought that Wilde is singled out for special treatment because the establishment wants to make an example of him, and they come down, as it were, especially hard on him. That's not the case. So even at this point, he has a special cell at Holloway. He's allowed to have food from a restaurant. He's given books, can read letters. He has a succession of visitors. His one great visitor is Bosie, Lord Alfred Douglas, who we described as this terrible...
阿瑟·查尔斯法官主持审判。他是一个保守派。他是一个失败的保守派政治家。但第二次审判令人惊讶的一点是，非常明显——我想我们并没有剧透——从一开始，阿瑟·查尔斯法官就对王尔德带有偏见。是的，这真的很出乎意料，不是吗？这根本不是人们对这场审判的普遍看法。
A baggage. A baggage, just putting it mildly. He's basically the worst man in the world. Wilde describes him as a slim thing, gold-haired like an angel who stands always at my side, moving in the gloom like a white flower. So. So fair to say that there are, you know, rival opinions on Bosie. What we can say about Bosie is that Bosie is so devoted to Wilde and is such a decent fellow that he leaves London for France just before the trial begins. Anyway, so the trial begins on Friday, the 26th of April, 1895.
因为在接下来的五天左右时间里，你看到了一连串的证人。我通过朗读马修·斯特吉斯传记中的一段摘录来让你粗略感受一下。威廉·帕克讲述了在凯特纳餐厅吃晚饭时，他的弟弟曾多次接受王尔德亲手喂的蜜饯樱桃。阿尔弗雷德·伍德讲述了在凯特纳餐厅吃晚饭时，他的弟弟曾多次接受王尔德亲手喂的蜜饯樱桃。
Mr. Justice Arthur Charles is presiding. He is a conservative. He is a failed conservative politician. But a surprising thing about this second trial is that it's pretty obvious, and I think we're not giving the game away, by saying right from the beginning, Mr. Justice Charles is biased towards Wilde. Yeah, it's really unexpected, isn't it? That's not what the popular sense of the trial is at all.
阿尔弗雷德·伍德讲述了在佛罗伦萨餐厅的一个私人包厢吃晚饭时，王尔德把手伸进了伍德的裤子里。弗雷德·阿金斯描述了他是如何从红磨坊回来，发现王尔德正和莫里斯·施瓦伯在床上。爱德华·雪莱勉强承认王尔德在奥弗涅酒店吃过晚饭后亲吻并拥抱了他。事情就这样没完没了地继续下去。你看到了一连串的证人。
Because what happens in the next sort of five days is you have a succession of witnesses. I'll just give you a brief flavour of it by reading an extract from Matthew Sturgis' biography. So you have William Parker telling of how, over dinner at Kettner's, his brother had repeatedly accepted preserved cherries from Wilde's own mouth. Alfred Ward recounting how, over dinner at Kettner's, his brother had repeatedly accepted preserved cherries from Wilde's own mouth.
现在，爱德华·克拉克爵士——值得高度赞扬的是，他是王尔德在前一次失败的诽谤案中的大律师，顺便说一句，王尔德曾对他说过谎。爱德华·克拉克爵士极其英勇地表示，我和我的团队将免费为您提供服务，在这起案件中为您辩护。爱德华·克拉克爵士的论点是这些人是骗子。他们在敲诈王尔德。皇家控方是建立在一派胡言之上的。
Alfred Wood recounting how, during dinner in a private room at the Florence restaurant, Wilde had put his hand inside Wood's trousers. Fred Atkins describing how he'd come back from the Moulin Rouge to find Wilde in bed with Maurice Schwaber. Edward Shelley reluctantly confessing that Wilde had kissed and embraced him after supper at the Auvergne Hotel. And so it goes on and on and on. You have a succession of witnesses.
这些人以罪犯、社会渣滓和所有这类人的身份自证其罪。所以案件不是，哦，王尔德做了这件事，他这样做是对的。而是他根本没做过，对吧？这就是他发表“不敢说出名字的爱”演讲的背景，是的，这暗示了在某种程度上，他与男人的这种关系是高尚的、纯洁的，而且不是性关系。是的，在第四天，爱德华·克拉克爵士，王尔德的大律师，发表了这场非常激昂的辩护。他说，王尔德先生不是一个普通人，你知道的，你不应该
Now, Sir Edward Clarke, to his great credit, Wilde's barrister from the previous, from the failed libel case, to whom Wilde had lied, by the way. Sir Edward Clarke incredibly gallantly says, I and my team will give our services to you for free to defend you in this case. Sir Edward Clarke's argument is these people are liars. They are blackmailing Wilde. The Crown case is based on a pack of lies.
根据他的作品来谴责他，他对这些年轻人非常坦诚，对他们很慷慨——我认为这绝对是真的，我也这么认为。我的意思是，他很慷慨，也很善良。他说，你知道的，他和这些男人的关系中没有什么不道德的地方——这其实完全不是真的。于是我们迎来了第五天。那是 5 月 1 日，星期三。法官阿瑟·查尔斯爵士必须做总结陈词。我认为这太不可思议了。
These people are condemned out of their own mouths as criminals, as lowlifes, as all this kind of thing. So the case is not, oh, Wilde did it and he was right to do it. It's that he didn't do it at all, isn't it? And this is the context where he gives the love that dare not speak its name yeah speech it's implying that to the degree that there is this um relationship that he has with men it's ennobling and purifying and it is not sexual yeah and on the fourth day sredwell clark wilde's barrister gives this very rousing defense world he says mr wilde is not an ordinary man um you know you shouldn't
他的总结陈词非常明显地偏向奥斯卡·王尔德。他说，你知道的，不要根据他的作品来判断他。有时他的作品——如果允许我自己批评他的作品的话——是愚蠢的，但并不邪恶。不。然后他继续说道，像奥斯卡·王尔德这样的人会如此鲁莽，这合乎情理吗？是的。我的意思是，这是他说的关键点，因为他无法理解王尔德怎么会提起诽谤诉讼或者做任何……你知道的，如果这些都是真的话。他说，他怎么可能把男孩们带到萨伏伊酒店的床上，而且几乎不试图隐瞒，这合乎情理吗？当然，我们知道，因为我们在
condemn him on the basis of his writings he has been incredibly open with these young men generous to them which i think is absolutely true i think so i mean he has been generous and he has been kind and he says uh you know there was nothing indecent about his relationships which is not true with these men at all. And so we get to the fifth day. That's Wednesday, the 1st of May. And Sir Arthur Charles, the judge, has to give his summing up. And I think this is extraordinary.
第一集里做过节目，这是合乎情理的，但对法官这位失败的托利党议员或准议员来说，一个聪明的人会表现得如此灾难性地鲁莽，似乎完全不可能……他指出，王尔德有权要求你们记住，他是一个具有高度智力天赋的人，是一个人们会认为没有能力做出这种行为的人。再次，这迎合了王尔德在那场伟大演讲中的论点，即这其中包含着某种柏拉图、莎士比亚和米开朗基罗的成分。是的。所以他接受了王尔德所说的话。
His summing up is very clearly partisan towards Oscar Wilde. He says, you know, don't judge him by his writings. Sometimes his writing, if I may be allowed to criticize his writings myself, they are silly, but wicked. No. Then he goes on to say, is it plausible that a man such as Oscar Wilde would have been so reckless? Yeah. I mean, that's the key thing he's saying, because he cannot fathom that Wilde would have brought the libel or done any you know yeah if any of this had been true and he says is it plausible that he would have had boys in his bed in the savoy and there would have been so little attempt at concealment i mean of course we know because we
于是陪审团退席了。他们在一点半退席。时间流逝。陪审团要求吃午饭。最后，在五点一刻，陪审团回到法庭。仿佛这还不够好莱坞化一样，他们宣读了裁决。没有达成一致。没有裁决。他们无法达成一致。政府律师，或者说皇家律师查尔斯·吉尔说，我们毫无疑问会要求进行另一场审判。
did episode one that it is plausible but to the judge this failed tory mp or would be mp it seems utterly unlikely that an intelligent man would have behaved in such a catastrophically reckless... He points out, Wilde has the right to ask you to remember that he is a man of highly intellectual gifts, a person whom people would suppose incapable of such acts. And again, that is buying into Wilde's argument in that great speech, that there's something of Plato and Shakespeare and Michelangelo about this. Yeah. So he is accepting what Wilde says.
当王尔德被送出去时，将会有第三次审判。此时，进行了一些讨论。一位爱尔兰民族主义议员 T.M.希利对副总检察长弗兰克·洛克伍德爵士说，不要再把王尔德送上法庭了。而副总检察长实际上说，如果不是为了针对罗斯伯里勋爵、针对首相的恶劣谣言，我是不会这么做的。是的，这就是我们在第一集里谈到的，这种感觉，即首相罗斯伯里勋爵与昆斯伯里侯爵的长子卷入了一段同性恋关系。所以这一切都是一个巨大的暗示和推测的网络，一直延伸到政府的最高层。确实如此。现在，爱德华·卡森爵士，王尔德在都柏林三一学院的老同窗，常被视为这场伟大戏剧中的反派，据称他也向
So the jury go out. They go out at half past one. The hours go by. The jury call for lunch. And then finally, at quarter past five, the jury come back into court. And as if this wasn't the stuff of Hollywood already, they deliver their verdict. There is no agreement. There is no verdict. They can't agree. The government's lawyer, or the Crown's lawyer, Charles Gill, says, we will undoubtedly call for another trial.
政府发出呼吁，对他们说，我认为你们不应该再次将王尔德送上法庭。因此，罗斯伯里勋爵本人对他的内政大臣赫伯特·阿斯奎斯（王尔德曾在其餐桌上用过餐）说，我们放过他吧？我们就这么算了吧？而阿斯奎斯说，我们不能。如果我们这样做，我们就会输掉大选。多米尼克，重申一下，罗斯伯里此时处于虚脱状态。尽管大选即将来临，他基本上还是躺在黑暗的房间里。不仅仅是因为在媒体上，现在有报道称这是阴谋的一部分。
And while it is sent out, there is going to be trial number three. Now, at this point, there is some discussion. Some MPs, an Irish nationalist MP, T.M. Healey, says to the Solicitor General, Sir Frank Lockwood, do not put Wilde on trial again. And the Solicitor General actually says, I would not do so but for the abominable rumours against Lord Rosebery, against the Prime Minister. Yeah, so this is what we were talking about in the first episode, this sense that the Prime Minister, Lord Rosebery, has been involved in a same-sex relationship with the eldest son of the Marquess of Queensbury. So it is all a kind of great matrix of innuendo, supposition, that kind of reaches to the absolute top of the government. It does indeed. Now, Sir Edward Carson, Wilde's old Trinity College Dublin classmate, often seen as the villain of this great drama, he apparently also appeals to
存在着这样一个庞大的同性恋男性的网络——正如我们现在所称的那样，或者如 1890 年代的人所称的鸡奸者——他们掩盖了这一切，并试图让王尔德脱罪。因此，政府觉得他们实际上不能放过此事。我想他们内心深处希望王尔德去法国。而他的朋友们仍然在说……对。所以关键是，此时为王尔德缴纳了保释金，王尔德获得了保释。所以再次，当局似乎对王尔德有一种鼓励，让他离开，去法国。但他没有。原因之一可能是他的母亲，
the government and says to them, I don't think you should put Wilde on trial again. So Lord Rosebery, he himself says to Herbert Asquith, his home secretary, at whose table Wilde had dined, should we let him off? Should we just let this go? And Asquith says, we can't. If we do so, we will lose the election. And Dominic, just to reiterate, Rosebery at this point is in a state of prostration. And even though the election is approaching, he is basically just kind of lying in a dark room. Not least because in the press, there are now stories saying this is part of a conspiracy.
斯佩兰扎，王尔德对她极其孝顺，她说如果他逃跑，她将不再视他为儿子。而如果他留下来，即使他去坐牢，她依然会爱他。所以部分原因可能是——他只是僵住了，他在他的朋友列维顿夫妇家，他们把他安置在——我的意思是，这是一个令人难以置信的细节——他们把他安置在儿童育儿室里，他就坐在地板上，周围都是摇马、陀螺和所有这些东西……兔子和毛绒玩具，他的律师来育儿室咨询他，他就坐在那里，他只是一个破碎的人，他们传达了消息，他们说，你知道的，政府不会放过你的，事实上副总检察长弗兰克·洛克伍德
There is this huge network of gay men, as we would call them, sodomitical men, as they would have called them in the 1890s, who have covered this up and they're trying to get Wilde off. So the government feel they actually can't let this go. I think they wish, deep down, that Wilde would go to France. And his friends are still saying... Right. And so the key thing is, is that at this point, bail is posted for Wilde and Wilde is granted bail. So again, there seems to be a kind of encouragement from the authorities to Wilde, to go away, go to France. But he doesn't. And maybe one of the reasons is that his mother,
已经宣布他将亲自起诉这第三次审判。他要亲自来做这件事，因为皇家想要彻底结束这一切。他们想这么做。王尔德仍然由爱德华·克拉克爵士代表，依然是免费辩护。我的意思是，他免费放弃了这么多时间真是太不可思议了，因为他为第一次审判感到非常糟糕，顺便说一句，在第一次审判中，他自己的客户对他说过谎。与此同时，王尔德必须支付诉讼费。王尔德实际上已经破产了。因为波西曾承诺资助，却溜之大吉去了欧洲大陆，
Speranza, to whom Wilde is devoted, says that if he flees, she will no longer regard him as her son. Whereas if he stays, and even if he goes to prison, she will still love him. So maybe part of it so he's just frozen he's at his friends the levitons they put him up in i mean it's just an unbelievable detail they put him up in the child's nursery and he's just sitting there on the floor surrounded by rocking horses and you know spinning tops and all these kinds of things um rabbits and and stuffed toys and his his lawyers come to consult him in the nursery and he's sitting there and he's just a broken man and they and they deliver the news they say you know it's the government are not going to let you off in fact the solicitor general's frank lockwood
留下了王尔德一个人去面对这一切后果。审判于 5 月 22 日开幕。我的意思是，这一切都在短短几周内发生。是的。这就是为什么它如此戏剧性，
has announced that he is going to prosecute this third trial personally he's going to do this personally because the crown want to make an end of this now. They want to do it. Wilde is still represented by Sir Edward Clarke, still doing it for free. I mean, extraordinary that he's giving up so much time for free because he feels so bad about the first trial, in which his own client had lied to him, by the way. Meanwhile, Wilde has to pay costs. Wilde is bankrupt, effectively. Because Bosie had promised to fund it and has skedaddled to the continent,
因为几乎是日复一日地出现新的情况。这是维多利亚时代的报纸不习惯处理的那种细节，它就这样一周又一周地爆出。
leaving Wilde in every way to face the music. So the trial opens on the 22nd of May. I mean all this is within just a few weeks. Yeah. That's what makes it so dramatic
所以 5 月 22 日的案件，他们回到了老贝利法院。此时的王尔德已经是一个心碎之人，所以我们之前谈到了那种——那种浮华轻佻、几乎是傲慢的态度，他在第一次案件一开始时表现出的那种态度，现在全都消失了。他面容憔悴，沉默寡言，孤言寡语。他知道那样的灾难……不过他仍然心存侥幸，不是吗？因为审判仍在继续，我的意思是，我们不需要重复，因为基本上它就是
that it's sort of day after day new. And it's detail of a kind that you know Victorian newspapers are not used to handling and it's just coming out week after week
之前发生的一切的重演，现在他紧紧抓住希望，也许陪审团会像之前的陪审团那样看待事情，你知道的，因为如果再次没有做出裁决，那么我想这个案子就会被撤销。因此，当他们在等待裁决时，洛克伍德对克拉克说，你明天将在巴黎请你的当事人吃晚餐，但克拉克自己却说，不，我不这么认为。是的，这太不可思议了，副总检察长决心亲自起诉此案，在 5 月 25 日星期六，当他们在等待裁决时，他实际上认为我可能没有赢得这场官司，我可能没有稳操胜券，不仅仅是因为这一次又是一个不同的法官，这次他对王尔德不那么有利，但也不是过分反对王尔德——我的意思是他的总结
after week. So the 22nd of May case they return to the Old bailey uh wild is kind of a broken man at this point so we talked before about the sort of um the sort of foppish flippancy the arrogance almost with which he conducted himself at the very beginning of the first case is all gone he is haggard he is quiet he is withdrawn he knows that the sort of disaster he's still hoping though isn't he because the trial goes ahead and i mean we don't need to reiterate it because basically it's a
陈词相当中庸，他没有真正偏向任何一方，尽管正如我们将看到的，当裁决宣读时，结果证明王尔德被判有罪。他们已经商议了两个小时，对吧？他们商议了两个小时，陪审团。随着时间的流逝，王尔德的团队变得乐观起来。陪审团离开的时间越长，他们无法达成一致的机会就越大。政府不会在诽谤审判之外再提起第三次审判。他们回来了，并且在几乎每一项指控上都宣判有罪。
rehashing of everything that's gone before and there is now he's clinging to the hope that perhaps the jury will kind of see things as as the previous jury had done and you know because if it's again there is no decision reached then i think it will be abandoned and so as they're waiting for the the verdict um lockwood says to clark you'll dine your man in paris tomorrow but clark himself says no i don't think so yeah this is extraordinary the solicitor general who's determined to prosecute the case personally on saturday the 25th of may as they're waiting for the verdict that he actually thinks i probably haven't won this i probably haven't secured it not least because once again it's a different judge this time he's less pro wild but he's not excessively anti-wild i mean his summing
我想有一项指控他被判无罪，但其余所有的都被判有罪。正是在那时，威尔斯法官（Justice Wills）戴上了相当于黑帽子的法官帽，宣布这是我审理过的最糟糕的案件。你王尔德是一场针对年轻人的、范围广泛且极其丑恶的广泛腐败的核心。这是毫无疑问的，然后他宣判了法律允许的最严厉的刑期：两年监禁并强制劳动，他接着说，在我看来，对于这样的案件来说，这完全是不够的。所以你选错了职业。你会成为一个出色的、带有布拉克纳尔夫人（Lady Bracknell）风格的晚期维多利亚时代绞刑法官。我可能对威尔斯法官不公平。我确信他听起来不那样。
up is pretty sort of he doesn't really veer one way or the other although as we will see when the verdict is delivered and it turns out that Wilde has been found guilty. They've gone for two hours, haven't they? They've gone for two hours, the jury. As the minutes tick by, Wilde's team become optimistic. The longer the jury are out, the more chances there is that they can't agree. The government aren't going to bring a third trial on top of the libel trial. They come back in and they just say on count after count, guilty.
但当你读到那段话时，我的意思是，这是一种非常、非常毁灭性的反应。对于王尔德来说，我的意思是，他瘫倒了，他——我的意思是，这太感人了，因为这个靠着文字才华谋生、成名并建立声誉的人，短暂地似乎说不出话来。然后他大喊道：“我什么也不能说吗，大人？”但他不能。法官挥手让他保持沉默。王尔德被匆忙带出被告席，走下楼梯。仅就审判而言。我的意思是，我们的同情心显然倾向于王尔德。
I think one count he's found not guilty, but all the rest he's found guilty. And it's then that Justice Wills, you know, puts on the equivalent of a black cap and declares that it is the worst case I have ever tried. That you wild have been the center of a circle of extensive corruption of the most hideous kind among young men. It is impossible to doubt and he then delivers a sentence which is the heaviest that he can legally deliver two years imprisonment with hard labor and in my judgment he says it is totally inadequate for such a case as this so you've you've missed your vocation. You would have made a splendid late Victorian hanging judge of the Lady Bracknell kind. I'm probably being unfair to Justice Wills. I'm sure he didn't sound like that.
你知道的，他是这一切中的受害者。21世纪的听众如果不为这个人感到难过，那将是不自然的。但当然，事实是，王尔德的毁灭部分是由他自己的鲁莽造成的。他的毁灭是因为他针对昆斯伯里
But when you read that, I mean, it's kind of very, very devastating reaction. And for Wilde, I mean, he slumps and he, I mean, it's so moving because this man who has made his living and his fame and his reputation out of his brilliance with words, he briefly seems unable to speak. And then he cries out, and I may I say nothing, my Lord. And he can't. The justice, the judge kind of waves him silent. And Wilde is hurried out of the dock, down the stairs. Just on the trials. I mean, our sympathy, obviously, is drawn to Wilde.
侯爵提起了那场诽谤诉讼。我想你会为他辩护说，他觉得自己被困住了，他觉得必须解决这个问题，他觉得自己别无选择，但当然，就案件本身而言，用你的话来说，汤姆，他确实是罪证确凿。是的，他确实是——我的意思是，按照当代的标准，他确实和这些家伙一起犯下了所有这些轻罪。而且，你知道，判他有罪并不是冤假错案。汤姆，你同意他被判有罪吗？是的，我的意思是，根据当时的精神法律，他显然是有罪的。整个国家基本上都赞同这一点。
You know, he is the victim in all this. It would be unnatural for a 21st century listener not to feel sorry for this man. But of course, the truth is, Wilde is partly the author of his own demise because of his own recklessness. He's the author of his own demise because he brought that libel case against the marcus
对裁决的支持是压倒性的。我的意思是，仍然有声音为王尔德辩护。所以W.B.叶芝，他的朋友，你知道的，那位伟大的诗人，他把这一切描述为一场“庸俗狭隘者的狂欢”，我认为这是一个人们现在会更有共鸣的视角。不过，就这种庸俗狭隘者的狂欢而言，W.B.叶芝反对的不是法律，不是维多利亚时代英国的整个道德结构。而是因为他认为王尔德是一位艺术家，王尔德是特殊的，因此王尔德不应该像普通人那样被审判。我说的对吗？是的，但我认为有一种感觉，即英国在观点和判断上具有奇特的庸俗狭隘性。我认为，在某种程度上，这是一种混合体。这将对这些审判的遗产产生重要影响，
of greensby i suppose you would say in his defense he felt that he was trapped he felt he had to settle the issue he felt there was nothing else he could do but of course on the merits of the case he is to use your expression tom he is banged to rights yeah he is i mean he did by the standards of the day commit all these misdemeanors with these blokes. And, you know, it's not a miscarriage of justice that he is. Would you agree, Tom, that he's found guilty? Yeah, I mean, under the law of the time, he clearly is guilty. And the entire country basically agrees.
那就是模糊王尔德作为伟大作家和艺术家的身份，以及他在公众心目中被认定为同性恋者的身份——正是在同性恋这个概念开始作为社会公众理解的一种事物出现的时候——这将对于理解其长期影响至关重要。但我认为这也反映出，媒体的反应触及了英国人肯定仍会认为是英国公共生活特征的一个方面。这一点由波西阐明，他在谈到对王尔德的裁决时说，当伟大的英国公众下定
The overwhelming support for the verdict. I mean, there are voices that are still raised in Wales defence. So WB Yates, who is a friend of his, you know, the great poet, he describes the whole thing as an orgy of Philistine rancour, which I think is a perspective with which people now would have more sympathy. Just on that Philistine rancour, though, what WB Yates is objecting to is not the law, the entire moral structure of Victorian England. It's the fact that he thinks Wilde is an artist, Wilde is special, and therefore Wilde should not be judged like ordinary men. Am I right? Yeah, but I think that there is a sense that Britain is peculiarly Philistine in its opinions and its judgments. And I think that, yeah, to a degree, it's a kind of mixture. And this is going to be important for the kind of the legacy of these trials,
伟大的英国决心去摧毁任何落在它权力范围内的倒霉蛋时，它通常都能达到目的。波西，我必须说，他可能是我们在《历史的余烬》中谈论过的最糟糕的人。我简直无法忍受。也许除了希特勒？是的，他没有希特勒那么坏，但波西的表现一直都太糟糕了，不是吗？主动说他会付钱，然后又从不真正兑现，逃跑去法国，留下他的朋友去面对烂摊子。当然，波西也是一些最……你知道的，最鲁莽行为的罪魁祸首。无论如何，这都是题外话。
that the blurring of wild status as a great writer and an artist and his status as someone who has been identified in the public mind with homosexuality at precisely the time when the concept of homosexuality is starting to come in as something that people in society understand is going to be really crucial for understanding its long-term impact. But I think it also, the press reaction speaks to something that people in Britain certainly would still recognise is a feature of British public life. And it's articulated by Bosie, who says of the verdict that is given on Wilde, when the great British public has made up its
这只是我在发牢骚。无论如何，我们现在休息一下。王尔德已经被定罪了。他被带到了牢房。当我们回来时，我们将讨论他在监狱里的生活。好的，很好。奇阿拉。在意大利语里这也是“聪明”的意思，真遗憾你的咖啡师不会拼写。所以你只能用一个假名，比如你咖啡馆的名字，朱莉娅，但你用得越多，就越觉得自己在接受证人保护。等一下。朱莉娅到底喜欢什么样的浓缩咖啡？现在改拿铁还来得及吗？
great British mind to crush any particular unfortunate whom it holds in its power it generally succeeds in gaining its object bozzi i have to say it's probably the worst person we've ever talked about on the rest of history i i can't stand perhaps from hitler yeah he's not as bad as hitler but bozzi behaves so badly throughout doesn't he offering saying he'll pay and then he never quite does it and running away to fr, leaving his mate to face the music. And of course, Bosie, who's been responsible for some of the most, you know, the most reckless behavior. Anyway, this is by the by.
但如果你有一台 KitchenAid 的浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些烦恼了，因为你完全可以在家里自己做。立即访问 KitchenAid.ca 购买。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论，
This is just me ranting now. Anyway, so let's take a break now. Wilde has been convicted. He's been taken down to the cells. When we come back, we'll talk about what his life was like in prison. Yeah, very good. Chiara. It means smart in italian too bad your barista can't spell it right so you just give a fake name your cafe name julia but the more you use it the more it feels like you're in witness protection wait a minute what kind of espresso drinks does jul like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order?
还有一点八卦秀，在我们的问答环节，我们会拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们进入了这场涉及奥斯卡·王尔德的伟大戏剧的最后一幕。他现在是王室的囚犯，最初被带到纽门监狱，然后被带到佩顿维尔监狱。所以，重要的是要说，王尔德被判处两年强制劳动，但从一开始他们就说你不需要做强制劳动。你只需要做轻体力劳动，因为，你知道的，你的身体不适合强制劳动。
But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home. Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
我认为，即使在此时，在那些对王尔德不一定非常同情的人当中，也有一种感觉，即他与其他囚犯不同。他不必承受其他人所承受的监狱系统的每一个严厉惩罚。是的，我认为这反映了一种理解，即对王尔德来说，这种惩罚异常残酷。因此，有人写信给报纸，说这对他来说会比对比尔·赛克斯（来自《雾都孤儿》的那个凶手）更糟糕。也就是说，对于像王尔德这样具有敏感性和背景的人来说，强加给罪犯的痛苦……你知道的，要大得多。
splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. welcome back to the rest is history uh we're into the final act of this great drama involving oscar wilde he's now a prisoner of the crown he's taken initially to newgate and then to pentonville so i'm and important to say world was sentenced to two years with hard labor but right from the beginning they say you don't have to do the hard labor. You can just do light labor because, you know, you're not physically fit for the hard labor.
但我认为对王尔德来说独特的是，你知道的，他被单独监禁，不允许说话，囚犯之间禁止交流。而他是一个一生都在说话的人。交谈是他的伟大特长，你知道的，他特别擅长的事。正如马修·斯特吉斯所说，汤姆，王尔德，他为交谈而活，为社交活动而活，为智力刺激而活，为美、为舒适、为美食和安逸而活，
And I think there is a sense, even at this point, among people who are not necessarily terribly sympathetic to Wilde, that he is different from other prisoners. And he will not have to be subjected to every single rigor of the penal system that others are subjected to yeah and i think that that reflects an understanding that for wild the punishment is peculiarly awful so there are people who write to the papers and say that it will be worse for him than it would be for a bill sykes you know the the murderer from um from for all of the twist i.e that for someone of wild sensibilities and background the sufferings that are imposed on convicts you know far far greater
这一切都在一瞬间彻底失去了。恐惧压倒了他。当然，他作为一个追求极致品味的人而闻名。而进入监狱接受处理的一切都与此完全相反。所以他，你知道的，他被发给带有箭头标志的囚服。他的头发被剃光。为了防止他长虱子。他被喂食——他吃的是什么？他被给予溴化钾，这是为了抑制性欲。确实如此。这确实会抑制你的性欲。所有的囚犯都被给予这个，你知道的，为了抑制性欲。确实如此。这确实会抑制你的性欲，
but i think distinctively for wild he is you know he is in solitary confinement he's not allowed to talk there is a prohibition on communication between prisoners ande is a man who all his life has spoken. Conversation is his great, you know, the thing that he is peculiarly brilliant at. Exactly, as Matthew Sturgis says, Tom, Wilde, who had lived for conversation, for social intercourse, for intellectual stimulation, for beauty, for comfort, for good food and ease,
并且所有的囚犯都被给予这个，基本上是为了让他们在性方面失去活性。是的。当他们在……我的意思是，其中一位监狱牧师，
had lost them all absolutely and at a stroke. The horror of it overwhelmed him. And of course, he is famous as an Eastie to someone whose taste is exquisite. And everything about being processed into prison is the absolute opposite of that. So he is, you know, he's given the convict's uniform with the arrows on it. His hair is shaved. He's stopped him from getting lice. He's fed, what is he? He's given bromide of potassium, which is designed to suppress the libido. Which it does. It does suppress your libido. And that, all prisoners were given that, you know, to suppress the libido. Which it does. It does suppress your libido
顺便说一句，在王尔德所在的某个监狱，我不记得是哪个监狱了，说他怀疑他把所有时间都花在了
and all prisoners were given that to basically make them sexually inactive. Yeah. While they were... I mean, one of the prison chaplains,
在监狱里自慰，并声称他的牢房……是的，关于这方面的细节和问题一直上升到了内阁会议室。是的。我的意思是，令人震惊。王尔德是不是在牢房里自慰太多了？结果证明他没有。
by the way, in Wales, I can't remember which prison it is, says of him that he suspects that he's been spending all his time
但王尔德得了可怕的腹泻，严重的痢疾，他的健康甚至在监狱的那头几天和几周里就崩溃了。有一个可怕的故事，他们得到的锻炼很少，他们在监狱院子里转圈，他前面的那个人低声对他说——他们是不准说话的——前面那个人低声说：“我很同情你，王尔德先生。”王尔德对此感到无比震撼，以至于他大喊：“噢，谢谢你，谢谢你！”然后他被惩罚了，当然，你不准说话。王尔德是伟大的个人主义者，王尔德是一个……
masturbating in prison and claims that his cell... Yes, the details and questions about this are taken all the way up to the cabinet room. Yeah. I mean, astonishing. Is Wilde masturbating too much in his cell it turns out that he isn't
拒绝接受自己只是芸芸众生之一的人，你知道的，这就是他的艺术和情感生活的全部精髓。但现在连他的名字都被剥夺了。他只有一个编号。这就是他。他被吞没在这个可怕的监狱系统的运作之中。好吧，那种被抹去的感觉，汤姆。所以，顺便说一句，他的戏剧已经被下架了。甚至在美国也被下架了。
but while does get terrible diarrhea terrible dysentery his health collapses even in those first days and weeks in in prison there's a terrible story that um they get very little exercise they're going around the prison yard and the man in front of him whispers to him they're not allowed to speak the man in front whispers says i'm very sorry for you mr wild and wild is so overwhelmed by this that he shouts out oh thank you thank you and he is then he's punished of course you're not allowed to speak and and wild is the great individualist wild is the person who um refuses to accept that he is one of the crowd you know, this is the whole essence of his artistic and emotional life.
但与此同时，他开始严重腹泻、患上严重的痢疾，甚至在入狱的最初几天和几周里，他的健康状况就崩溃了。有一个可怕的故事：他们几乎没有锻炼的机会，在监狱院子里散步时，前面的人低声对他说——他们是不准说话的——前面的人低声说“我很同情你，王尔德先生”。王尔德对此感动不已，大声喊道：“哦，谢谢你，谢谢你！”随之他受到了惩罚，因为当然是不准说话的。王尔德是个伟大的个人主义者，他拒绝承认自己只是乌合之众中的一员，你知道的，这正是他艺术与情感生活的全部精髓。
But now even his name has been taken away from him. He just has a number. That is who he is. He's absorbed into the kind of the processing of this terrifying penal system. Well, that sense of erasure, Tom. So his plays, by the way, have been taken off. They've been taken off even in America.
但现在，连他的名字也被剥夺了。他只有一个编号。这就是现在的他。他被这个可怕的惩罚体系的机器所吞没。没错，汤姆，那种被抹杀的感觉。顺便说一句，他的戏剧也被停演了。甚至在美国，它们也都被停演了。
The Western Mail, Welsh newspaper, this thing about what being erased this is what the leader said when he was imprisoned oscar wilde will never again be anything but a memory a beacon light set up to warn youth from the dangers that lurk in a life of ease and pleasure his personality has been wiped out from the haunts of men and his name has become a byword and a reproach yeah so that sense that uh that actually in the press we will now just he's been he's been cancelled actually it has been but interestingly not by the lib the governing liberal establishment this is what's so intriguing isn't it that still there are people high up in the government who seem to be looking out for him. So on the 12th of June, so he's not even two weeks into his sentence, we talked about Herbert Asquith, the Home Secretary, future Prime Minister.
《西方邮报》，这份威尔士报纸，关于他被抹杀这件事——这就是领袖在入狱时所说的话：奥斯卡·王尔德将永远只是一段记忆，一盏竖起的灯塔，旨在警告年轻人警惕安逸和享乐生活中潜藏的危险，他的人格已经从人类的出没之地被彻底抹去，他的名字已成为代名词和耻辱。是的，所以那种感觉，实际上在媒体上我们现在就会发现——他其实已经被取消了。事实也的确如此，但有趣的是，这样做并不是由自由派的执政精英阶层发起的——这不是很耐人寻味吗？政府高层似乎仍然有人在暗中照顾他。所以在6月12日，他服刑甚至还不到两周的时候——我们之前聊过赫伯特·阿斯奎斯，内政大臣、未来的首相。
One of his two or three best friends, another Liberal MP, Richard Haldane, future War Minister, he comes to Sea Wild in prison, makes a special trip to see him, and talks to him about books, about literature, and says, listen, we're going to do what we can for you. We will get you books. What books would you like? Wilde says very foolishly, I'd like some of the novels of Gustav Flaubert. And Haldane says to him, well, he was in fact prosecuted himself for indecency. So I'm not convinced that those are the ideal books for you to be delivered, but they agree that he will have St. Augustine,
他的两三个至交好友之一，另一位自由党议员理查德·霍尔丹，未来的战争大臣，他来到雷丁监狱探望王尔德，专门跑去见他，跟他聊书籍、聊文学，并对他说：“听着，我们会为你尽力而为的。我们会给你弄来书。你想要什么书？”王尔德非常愚蠢地回答：“我想读一些古斯塔夫·福楼拜的小说。”霍尔丹对他说：“嗯，他本人其实也曾因伤风败俗而被起诉。所以我不确信这些是适合送给你的理想书籍。”但他们商定，他可以读圣奥古斯丁、
Cardinal Newman, Walter Pater's Renaissance, which is very, a big history of Rome. Yeah. He will get special treatment because other prisoners are not allowed books. But Haldane says, we will bring you the books.
纽曼枢机主教、沃尔特·佩特的《文艺复兴》——那是一本关于罗马的大部头历史书。是的。他将获得特殊待遇，因为其他囚犯是不允许看书的。但霍尔丹说：“我们会把书带给你。”
Haldane talks to asquith they said they have they commission a report to see if wild is being properly treated is he being unfairly treated the head of the prison commission is a man called evelyn ruggles bryce of course he is and uh and he also says let's make you know we must we don't want to kill him we don't want him to be to be bullied. We must make sure that he is a special person. He is an exceptional talent, and we must make sure that he does actually get the special treatment that his status deserves. Now that, I have to say, Tom, until we researched this, I had no sense that anybody was looking out for him at all. So there are certain figures within the prison system who are clearly kind of very doctrinaire, apply the absolute letter of the law, who have no sympathy for Wilde whatsoever. But again and again, there are figures, so governors, warders, who do feel sympathy for him and express that sympathy.
霍尔丹和阿斯奎斯交谈，他们说——他们委托了一份报告，以查明王尔德是否受到了公正对待，他是否受到了不公正的对待。监狱委员会的负责人是一个名叫伊夫林·鲁格尔斯-布里斯的人——当然是的——而且他也说，让我们确保——你知道的，我们不想弄死他，我们不想让他受到欺凌。我们必须确保他是一个特殊的人。他是一个杰出的天才，我们必须确保他确实得到了与其地位相称的特殊待遇。现在，我得说，汤姆，在我们做这个研究之前，我根本没觉得有人在照顾他。因此，监狱系统内部的某些人物显然是非常教条主义的，他们绝对死板地执行法律，对王尔德毫无同情心。但一次又一次地，有一些人物，比如监狱长、狱警，确实对他抱有同情，并表达了这种同情。
And actually, the true hostility is coming from the public. And so there is one particularly notorious episode that illustrates this where he is being transferred from london to redding jail well the fact he's being transferred at all tom he's been transferred to a country prison because the authorities think he'll be better off in a country prison and they don't want to crush him in a city prison go on sorry i interrupted you And so he is taken to Clapham Junction railway station and he is forced to stand between his warders for half an hour on one of the platforms at Clapham Junction and people recognise him. And a large crowd gathers around him and they laugh and jeer and one man spits at him. And Wilde writes later that for a year after that was done to me, I wept every day at the same hour and
而实际上，真正的敌意来自于公众。因此有一个特别臭名昭著的插曲说明了这一点：当时他正被从伦敦转移到雷丁监狱——好吧，事实上他被转移了，汤姆，他被转移到了一座乡村监狱，因为当局认为他在乡村监狱会过得更好，他们不想在城市监狱里压垮他。说下去，抱歉我打断了你。于是他被带到克拉珀姆十字火车站，他被迫在克拉珀姆十字的一个站台上，在狱警之间站了半个小时，人们认出了他。一大群人围拢过来，他们嘲笑并起哄，还有一个男人向他吐口水。王尔德后来写道，在那件事发生后的一年里，我每天都在同一时间、
for the same space of time. Yes, it's very moving actually. Anyway, off he goes to Reading. He's there for the last 18 months of his sentence. Life is a bit better off in Reading. It's cleaner air. It was built on the site of a leper colony. Really? That's a good fact. He becomes a
持续同样长的时间哭泣。是的，这真的很感人。不管怎样，他去了雷丁。他在那里度过了刑期的最后18个月。雷丁的生活稍微好过一点。那里的空气更干净。它建在一个麻风病人隔离区的旧址上。真的吗？这倒是个冷知识。在公众眼中，他变成了一个
leper in the eyes of the public. He doesn't like the governor, Lieutenant Colonel Isaacson. He describes him as a man with the eyes of a leper in the eyes of the public. He doesn't like the governor, Lieutenant Colonel Isaacson. He describes him as a man with the eyes of a ferret, the body of an ape, and the soul of a rat. Yes, but then Isaacson gets replaced by a new governor, Major James O. Nelson, who Wilde says is the most Christ-like man he'd ever met. Because he, I mean, basically, it may be that nelson is the person who stops wild from maybe from dying from from having a complete breakdown because he does treat him with with incredible kindness and empathy because most of the people in in reading prison
麻风病人。他不喜欢监狱长、中校艾萨克斯。他把艾萨克斯形容为一个有着雪貂般的眼睛、猿猴般的身体和老鼠般的灵魂的人。是的，但后来艾萨克斯被一位新监狱长詹姆斯·奥·纳尔逊少校取代了，王尔德说纳尔逊是他见过最像基督的人。因为他——我的意思是，基本上，纳尔逊可能就是那个阻止王尔德走向死亡、阻止他彻底崩溃的人，因为他确实以难以置信的善良和同情心对待王尔德，因为雷丁监狱里的绝大多数人
are people from the reading and the surrounding villages who have been guilty of misdemeanors thefts you know they're working class young blokes. And for Major Nelson, Wilde is actually a treat. They have regular meetings, they chat about books. He says to Wilde, why don't you decide what books you should have in the prison library? He allows Wilde to have a notebook, to have a pen. Yeah, he is allowed to write. And the great thing that he writes in this time is a letter to Bosie, which stretches to 100 pages, which again, quite contrary to the law, you're not allowed to take anything you write in prison, you're not allowed to take out with you. Wilde does end up taking it out with him. And he gives it to Robert Ross, who becomes his literary executor. And in
都是来自雷丁及周边村庄、犯有轻罪或偷盗罪的人，你知道的，都是些工人阶级的年轻小伙子。对纳尔逊少校来说，王尔德其实是一种款待。他们定期会面，闲聊书籍。他对王尔德说：“你为什么不自己决定监狱图书馆里应该有什么书呢？”他允许王尔德拥有一个笔记本、一支笔。是的，他被允许写作。他在这一时期写下的伟大作品是一封写给博西的信，长达100页——这同样完全违背了法律，你在监狱里写的东西是不允许带出去的。王尔德最终还是把它带了出去。他把它交给了罗伯特·罗斯，后者成为了他的文学遗嘱执行人。不久之后，
due course, this is given the name De Profis and it's one of the the most moving pieces of of writing that the wild did absolutely kind of key part of the canon so that is testimony to the fact that wild is not being peculiarly persecuted in prison in fact quite the opposite and and wild himself in you know he in reading jail he becomes very popular not just with the with the governor but with his fellow inmates as well so i think he comes out really well from the the story of him in reading jail he he's very he's kind he's kind to the other prisoners he is unjudgmental and democratic in his relations with the warders he talks to them about books they get him to help them win newspaper competitions yeah so he wins for the one bloke he wins a silver tea service
这封信被命名为《自深深处》，它是王尔德写过的最感人的文字之一，绝对是其正文作品中的核心部分。这证明了这样一个事实：王尔德在监狱里并没有受到特别的迫害，事实恰恰相反。而且王尔德自己——你知道的，在雷丁监狱里，他不仅深得监狱长喜爱，也深得狱友们的喜爱。所以我觉得从他在雷丁监狱的故事中，他表现得非常好。他很善良，他对其他囚犯很好，他在与狱警交往时是不带偏见且民主的。他跟他们谈论书，他们让他帮他们赢得报纸比赛。是的，他帮其中一个家伙赢得了一套银质茶具
and a grand piano yeah by helping him fill in make all these witticisms to win these competitions and i think that what that shows is that his claim that the young men who he had been sleeping with that he had treated them as equals that he had treated them with kindness that he had shared his conversation with art about art and literature and so on as he he would with people of his own class and background, is actually true. Yeah, it's true, but it's not the whole story, right? Of course not. Of course not. He's in a position of power. He was in a position of power over these boys. I mean, I absolutely accept that.
和一台三角钢琴。是的，通过帮他填字、想出所有俏皮话来赢得这些比赛。我认为这表明他的说法——即他曾与之睡觉的年轻男子，他是把他们当作平等的人来对待的，他是怀着善良对待他们的，他曾与他们分享自己对艺术和文学等方面的对话，就像他与自己阶级和背景相同的人交往时一样——其实是真的。是的，这是真的，但这不是全部，对吗？当然不是。当然不是。他处于权力地位。他对这些男孩拥有权力地位。我的意思是，我完全承认这一点。
Listen, everybody who listens to this podcast will have a different view of this story. I think when you contemplate the story of this very rich, successful, articulate man having these relationships they're not really relationships are they having these brief assignations with very young 16 17 18 year old boys or young men who are poor who you know there are two ways you can interpret that one you can say it's fine they're having fun let them on. Another is to say there is a power dynamic there with which we in the 21st century are uncomfortable. so on that point,
听着，听这个播客的每个人对这个故事都会有不同的看法。我想，当你细想这个非常富有、成功、健谈的人与这些非常年轻的16、17、18岁男孩或年轻男子发生这些关系——这其实算不上什么关系，对吧？——与这些穷苦的男孩发生短暂的逢场作戏时……你知道的，有两种解读方式：一种你可以说这很好，他们玩得很开心，随他们去吧。另一种则是说，其中存在着一种权力动态，这是我们身处21世纪所感到不适的。所以在这一点上，
very interesting. WT, is it Stead? Yes. Stead, who is a campaigning newspaper editor. He highlights what he calls the white slave trade, the exploitation of young girls by rich and powerful men.
非常有趣。WT，是斯特德吗？是的。斯特德是一位积极倡导社会改革的报纸编辑。他强调了他所谓的“白奴贸易”，即富裕而有权势的男人对年轻女孩的剥削。
What is it? The maiden tribute of the modern babylon and stead has led a campaign to raise the age of consent for girls from 13 to 16 which he has done i think in the the 1880s and his commentary on the wild trial and conviction is to say, you have sentenced Wilde for his sleeping with young men, 16, 17, 18, but you are not charging men who are sleeping with female prostitutes of the same age. And he's making this point not to defend Wilde, but to highlight the fact that women are as subject to the exploitation by powerful men as as boys are yeah and i guess that that is actually a perspective that perhaps you know people still hold to in the 21st century yeah i think that's i think you're
这是什么？现代巴比伦的处女献礼，斯特德曾领导一场运动，将女孩的法定承诺年龄从13岁提高到16岁——我想他在19世纪80年代做到了这一点。他对王尔德审判和定罪的评论是：你们因为王尔德与年轻男子（16、17、18岁）发生性关系而判刑，但你们却没有起诉那些与同龄女性性工作者发生性关系的男人。他提出这一点不是为了辩护王尔德，而是为了强调这样一个事实：女性和男孩一样，同样遭受着权势男人的剥削。是的，我想这其实是21世纪的人们可能仍然持有的一个视角。是的，我想这——我想你
not wrong tom i think i think these are very you know these are very complicated issues and actually i wouldn't want to pronounce like a sort of sermonising vicar to the listeners because every listener will... Or indeed campaigners for the Me Too movement or, I don't know, Stonewall or whatever because they are also people who are holding a moral position.
并没有说错，汤姆。我认为这些——这些都是非常复杂的问题，实际上我不想像一个好为人师的牧师那样向听众发表高论，因为每一个听众都会……或者实际上，就像“我也是”运动（Me Too）的倡导者，或者石墙组织什么的，因为他们同样也是持有某种道德立场的人。
Morality has become, it's not just the preserve of vicars in the 21st century, but it's still very moral. It's an incredibly complex, ambivalent moral case. So we should, I think, before we just sum up what the long-term impact of this, and I think it does have a very, very big impact on the history of sexuality in Britain in particular,
道德已经成为——在21世纪，它不仅仅是牧师的专利，但它依然具有很强的道德色彩。这是一个极其复杂、矛盾的道德案例。因此，我认为，在我们总结这一切的长期影响之前——而且我认为这确实对英国特别是20世纪性行为的历史产生了非常非常大的影响，
in the 20th century. Well gets released. Yeah, 18th of May. So 18th, 19th of May. Again, the establishment don't want to humiliate him. So there's a lot of subterfuge. Basically, they move him to Pentonville.
王尔德获释了。是的，5月18日。所以是5月18日、19日。统治阶层不想羞辱他。所以这里面有很多掩人耳目的把戏。基本上，他们把他转移到了本顿ville监狱。
And there's a wonderful story, actually, Tom. I love this story from Matthew Sturgis's brilliant biography, which I can't recommend enough. Basically, he's smuggled out of Reading Prison.
实际上有一个很棒的故事，汤姆。我非常喜欢马修·斯特吉斯那本精彩传记里的这个故事，这本书我极力推荐。基本上，他被秘密带出了雷丁监狱。
He's going to be put on a train at Twyford to move him to London. And he's standing on the platform with his flank by his wardersers who are escorting him and he's there kind of incognito and it's the first time of course he's been out of the prison and he stands there on the platform it's a lovely day he sees a tree and he shouts oh beautiful world oh beautiful world he waves his arms and warder harrison says now mr wild you mustn't give yourself away like that you're the only man in england who would talk like that in a railway station which i think abusively captures the relationship between wild and his warders who are amused by him you know they like him actually
他将被带到特怀福德的火车站登上火车，以便将他转移到伦敦。他站在站台上，身旁簇拥着护送他的狱警，他当时算是隐姓埋名。当然，这是他自入狱以来第一次离开监狱。他站在站台上，那天天气很好，他看到了一棵树，大喊道：“哦，美丽的世界！哦，美丽的世界！”他挥舞着手臂，狱警哈里森说：“好了，王尔德先生，你不能这样暴露自己。你是全英国唯一一个会在火车站说这种话的人。”我觉得这句话非常精妙地捕捉到了王尔德和他的狱警之间的关系，他们觉得他很有趣，你知道的，他们其实挺喜欢他的。
yeah and what does come out from from this period is so likable doesn't he he's always likable i mean right the way through he is likable i think i would say lovable actually and that's what makes the ambivalences around his his record so complex i mean he is a lovable person i think the interesting thing there tom he comes out of prison and he's he's very keen that he says to his friends i'm a reformed character i behave badly i'm a reformed character i won't you, you know, go near young men again. I'm a changed man. And then, of course, over time. Can't help it.
是的，从这段时期流露出来的东西来看，他是多么讨人喜欢啊！他一直都很讨人喜欢。我的意思是，自始至终他都很讨人喜欢。我想我甚至可以说他是让人爱戴的。正是这一点，使得围绕他纪录的矛盾心理变得如此复杂。我的意思是，他是一个惹人喜爱的人。汤姆，我觉得有趣的是，他出狱后非常热切地对他的朋友们说：“我是一个改过自新的人。我以前行为不端，但我现在是一个改过自新的人了。我不会再……你知道的，再去接近年轻男子了。我是一个改变了的人。”然后，当然，随着时间的推移——
He can't help it. Because he goes abroad and he meets up with Bosie again. Bosie again. And, of course, he's been declared bankrupt while he's in prison. Yeah. So he has no money. So he's reliant on his wife. His wife, they have a formal, not a divorce, but a separation.
他控制不住自己。因为他去了国外，又和博西重逢了。又是博西。而且，当然，他在狱中时已被宣告破产。是的。所以他没有钱。因此他只能依靠他的妻子。他的妻子——他们之间进行了一次正式的离婚——不是离婚，而是分居。
Yeah. And she is giving him an allowance on the some on the understanding that he won't get back with bozy but he can't help it bozy basically kind of seduces him knowing this so again but their relationship now is very it's poisoned isn't it it's tempestuous yeah they're always rowing you know there's a sense of the fun has gone out of it for them i guess and they split up irrevocably and wilde spends the last year of his life uh in penury he dies in paris he's gone back into the old ways so um matthew sturgis says uh his monthly allowance was dedicated more to rent boys than to rent so he's kind of gone back to the old picking up young men again all that sort of uh stuff and he
是的。她给他一笔生活费，前提是条件他不准再跟博西混在一起。但他控制不住自己，博西明知这一点，基本上还是把他给诱惑了。所以，他们的关系现在又变得非常恶劣，不是吗？充满火药味。是的，他们总是争吵，你知道的，你会觉得那种乐趣对他们来说已经消失了。他们不可挽回地分开了，王尔德在极度贫困中度过了他人生的最后一年。他死在巴黎，又回到了老路上。所以，马修·斯特吉斯说，他每月的津贴与其说是用于支付房租，不如说是用来养牛郎的。所以他又回到了老路上，重新开始物色年轻男子，所有诸如此类的事情。然后他
dies he has an ear infection, doesn't he? Yeah, which he got from falling down in prison. And spreads into his brain, basically. Very sort of grim ending. He dies on the 30th of November, 1900, in penury, as you said, penniless,
去世了。他得了耳部感染，对吧？是的，那是他在监狱里摔倒引起的。基本上扩散到了他的大脑。一个非常阴暗的结局。他于1900年11月30日去世，正如你所说，身无分文、一贫如洗，
surrounded by his friends. So a lot of his friends are very loyal to him, aren't they? Yeah. He's a man who inspires loyalty. Yeah, loyalty. But yeah, the martyrdom. The martyrdom is what remains, right? The sense that he has been... Well, it's not just the martyrdom the martyrdom is what remains right the sense that
身旁环绕着他的朋友们。所以他的很多朋友对他非常忠诚，对吧？是的。他是一个能够激发出忠诚的人。是的，忠诚。但是，殉道。殉道才是留存下来的东西，对吧？那种他被……嗯，不仅仅是殉道，殉道才是留存下来的东西，对吧？那种
he has been well it's not just the martyrdom i think much more important than that initially is the said this before the association of wild with this novel and evolving concept of there being something called homosexuality which is kind of entering public discourse in britain at exactly this time and the concrete you know hasn't yet set but it sets in a kind of wild shape mold yeah and that means that for mainstream british opinion in the early years of the 20th century the concept of homosexuality wears the appearance of wild dandyism aestheticism flamboyance campness yeah but also a certain association with kind of pederastic and predatory and this of course is terrible for gay people because it associates them with sexual practices that are not at all
他被——嗯，不仅仅是殉道，我认为比这更重要的是，最初正如我们之前所说的那样，王尔德与一种当时正在英国公共话语中兴起的、关于“同性恋”这一小说的、不断演变的概念联系在了一起。这个概念的混凝土“尚未凝固”，但它却在一个王尔德式的模具中凝固了。是的，这意味着对于20世纪初英国的主流民意而言，“同性恋”这个概念带有一种王尔德式的花花公子气、唯美主义、浮夸和做作，但也带有一种与恋童癖和掠夺性行为的某种联系。当然，这对同性恋者来说是极其糟糕的，因为它将他们与那些根本不是同性恋者标配的性实践联系在了一起。
a given for gay people yeah and that the legacy of the wild trial explains why Britain is peculiarly hostile to gay people in the 20th century, really up until the 60s. I was going to say, you see that, think about 50s, 60s Britain
是的，王尔德审判的遗产解释了为什么英国在20世纪对同性恋者异常敌视，直到60年代左右都是如此。我正想说，你想想50、60年代的英国——
in the, I don't know, the Sunday pictorial or the mirror and the campaigns they would run against immoral men, against pansies
在——我不知道——《星期日画报》或《镜报》上，他们针对不道德的男人们、针对他们所谓的“娘娘腔”
as they would call them. I mean, the Sunday, what was it, one Sunday paper in the early 50s had a big double page spread a series, in fact, called How to Spot a Homo. men against pansies as they would call them yeah i mean the sunday was it the one paid sunday paper in the early 50s had a big double page spread a series in fact called how to spot a homo and it was kind of fondness for the theater uh dandyish clothes liking flowers and it's all wild it's all us go out exactly and that i think i think you're absolutely right that that rubs up against a sort of Puritanism in British culture,
所展开的各种运动。我的意思是，《星期日》——那是哪家报纸？50年代初有一家星期日报纸刊登了一个巨大的跨页专栏，实际上是一个系列，叫做“如何识别一个同性恋者”。针对他们所谓的“娘娘腔”的男人们。我的意思是，那家星期日——是哪家报纸？50年代初的一家星期日报纸有一个很大的跨页，实际上是一个系列，叫做“如何识别一个同性恋者”，内容包括对戏剧的爱好、花哨的衣服、喜欢花，这全都是王尔德那一套，全都是奥斯卡·王尔德那一套。完全正确。我认为——我认为你说得绝对没错，这与英国文化中的一种清教主义、一种对异类、对浮夸、对唯美主义的不信任发生了摩擦。但与此相对的是殉道者的成分。不仅如此，尽管王尔德出狱后确实表现出了一种悔悟，但这并没有持续多久，他死时对自己的所作所为和自己的过去毫无悔意。
a distrust of difference, of flamboyance, of aestheticism. But against that, the element of the martyrdom. But more than that, although when Wilde comes out of prison, he does express a kind of repentance, it doesn't last long and he dies unrepentant for what he has done and what he has been um he he doesn't feel a shame about his sexual identity he actually kind of glories in it yeah and he embodies a sense of pride in what he is that i think in the the later decades of the 20th century becoming you know crucially important for the way that gay identity evolves and emancipates itself from this kind of legacy of hatred it makes him an icon doesn't it yeah i mean he is as famous now i know you love his works you love his plays
他对他自己的性身份并不感到羞耻，他实际上为之感到荣耀。是的，他体现了一种对自身身份的自豪感，我认为这在20世纪的后几十年里，对于同性恋身份的演变及其从这种仇恨遗产中解放出来的方式变得至关重要。这使他成为了一个偶像，对吧？是的。我的意思是，他现在一样出名——我知道你热爱他的作品，你尤其热爱他的戏剧，
in particular but he is probably i would say more famous now as a martyr than he is as a writer do you think that's fair i know you love his stuff I think his status as a martyr is dependent on the fact that he is a genius. I think without that, he wouldn't have the stature and the standing that he does. But we've been very, very harsh on Bosie. But I just want to maybe end this episode
但他现在作为一个殉道者可能比作为一个作家更出名，你觉得这公平吗？我知道你很喜欢他的作品。我认为他作为殉道者的地位取决于他是一个天才这一事实。我认为如果没有这一点，他就不会拥有现在这样的声望和地位。不过，我们对博西的评价可能过于严厉了。但我只想用下面这段话来结束这一集，
by reading something that Bosie wrote in a letter to a literary journal three weeks after Wilde's conviction, which I think he does speak for attitudes that now have become completely normative. So this is a private letter written to an MP who had been very hostile to Wilde. And Bosey writes about what he calls Uranian love love the same sex love what we would call gay love i guess um these tastes are perfectly natural congenital tendencies in certain people a very large minority and the law has no right to interfere with these people provided they do not harm other people that is to say when there is neither seduction of minors or brutalization
读一读博西在王尔德被定罪三周后写给一家文学期刊的一封信。我认为他的话确实代表了如今已经完全成为规范的那些态度。所以这是一封写给一位曾对王尔德极具敌意的国会议员的私人信件。博西在信中写到了他所谓的“乌拉尼亚之爱”（Uranian love）——同性之爱，也就是我们现在所说的同性恋之爱：“这些品味对于某些人来说是完全自然、先天倾向，是一群极少数人，法律无权干涉这些人，只要他们不伤害其他人，也就是说，既没有对未成年人的诱惑，也没有野蛮行径，
and where there is no public outrage or morals and i guess that that is pretty much where the consensus is now it is a kind of irony upon irony because bozzi later in life as it were converted and became a catholic a very fervent opponent of homosexuality and an anti-semite a ferocious anti-semite so and and a further irony he libels winston churchill and gets sent to prison for it. Yeah. And there was some case with Arthur Ransom, wasn't there? The author of Swallows and Amazons.
并且没有引发公众对道德的愤怒。”我想，这差不多就是如今的社会共识所在。这真是一种讽刺中的讽刺，因为博西在晚年时皈依了天主教，成为了同性恋的狂热反对者，同时还是一个反犹太主义者、一个凶猛的反犹太主义者。还有一个讽刺之处，他因为诽谤温斯顿·丘吉尔而被判入狱。是的。而且好像还和亚瑟·兰瑟姆有过什么官司，对吧？《燕子与亚马逊河》的作者。
Such a strange... Yeah. A strange... His afterlife is very strange. Yeah. Sort of strange kind of maelstrom of allegations, rumors, court cases and... And ironies. The strangest thing of all, Tom, has been recording this episode in this park in Washington, D.C.,
太奇怪了……是的。太奇怪了……他身后发生的事非常奇怪。是的，充满了各种指控、谣言、法庭诉讼以及……种种讽刺，简直是一团奇异的漩涡。最奇怪的事情是，汤姆，我们在华盛顿特区的一个公园里录制这一集，
where basically there are just a stream of families going to a baseball game. And here we are. We've been having to cut short our discussions of Oscar Wilde's nocturnal activities every now and again as people are passing. Dirty sheets. Yeah.
这里基本上人来人往，全都是去看棒球比赛的家庭。而我们呢，每当有人路过时，我们都不得不时不时不时地中断我们对奥斯卡·王尔德夜间活动的讨论。脏床单。是的。
And so on. We've done a lot of Restless History episodes in odd circumstances, but I think that I can safely say this is the oddest. Anyway, thank you so much Tom.
诸如此类。我们在各种奇怪的环境下录制过很多《闲话历史》播客，但我可以说这绝对是最奇怪的一次。无论如何，非常感谢你，汤姆。
Thank you Dominic. Thank you everybody for listening and we will pack up our kit and go off and sample the delights of Washington
谢谢多米尼克。谢谢大家的收听，我们将收拾好装备去品尝华盛顿的美食，
and we will see you all next time. Bye bye. Bye bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们下期再见。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听《闲话历史》。如需收听独家番外、提前解锁节目、免广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com 本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。